narratives which continue for thousands
of years Galactic Civilizations that
span across hundreds thousands and even
millions of planets interplanetary
economies huge space military forces
capable of making ruins of entire worlds
there's something about empires among
the stars that really captured my
imagination from a very early age in
literary science-fiction depictions of
galactic empires are common the trend
was kicked off in the 1940s by legendary
science fiction writer Isaac Asimov in
his foundation series the foundation
series focused on the fall of an old
Galactic Empire and the rise of a new
one the foundation books paved the way
for other authors to create new
fictionalized empires among the stars in
this video I will be comparing the
galactic empires of the foundation
universe the dune universe from Frank
Herbert series and the Hyperion universe
from the science fiction series by Dan
Simmons which was published from 1989 to
1997
[Music]
in Asimov's Foundation series mankind
inhabited every part of the Milky Way
galaxy millions of worlds are inhabited
the full series including the robot
series and the Empire series spans over
the course of approximately 17,000
standard years
similarly in dune humankind has spread
to countless worlds within our galaxy
the dune encyclopedia measures the time
span of the dune universe at
approximately 34,000 years while the
Brian Herbert and Kevin J Anderson
expanded universe measures the time span
at just over 17,000 standard years the
Hyperion cantos has the least amount of
inhabited worlds and the shortest time
span when compared to the other to under
400 worlds have been colonized in the
Hyperion series and the time span
covered just under 1000 standard years
starting from the Year Zero in the
hegemony standard calendar Asimov
originally based his interstellar empire
on the Roman Empire like foreign Herbert
with his dune series azmuth was inspired
by the work of Edward Gibbons who wrote
the history of the decline and fall of
Rome a work comprised of six volumes
explaining the fall of the Roman Empire
and foundation the first Empire lasted
nearly 12,000 years before it began to
decline these changes had gone unnoticed
by all other than Harry Selden who
utilized a science known as psycho
history to predict the fall of the old
Empire and ensure the survival of the
new one as Mao's fictional Galactic
Empire could not exist if not for the
concept of hyperspace a sub-region of
space in which humans could travel
through at faster than light speed the
capital planet of the old Empire light
at the center of the galaxy it had been
called train tour and the military
forces of the Empire had been known as
the Imperial Navy over the course of the
foundation series the Empire is plunged
into centuries of decline and anarchy a
dark ages the foundations the first and
the second according to Harry Selden's
plan would eventually recreate the
Imperium by revitalizing the
scientifically quiescent and
technologically Static galaxy the
origins of humanity
in asthma a series has been lost to time
knowledge of Earth has almost entirely
faded Frank Herbert's dune series
contains a Galactic Empire full of
planets who do commerce their use of the
space and guilt who use faster than
light engines navigated by genetically
modified humans the chome company
controlled all affairs relating to
economics in the Imperium its board of
directors was controlled by the padishah
Emperor who resided on the planet kai
tain and the lands rad who consisted of
the noble houses of the Empire the Bene
Gesserit sisterhood existed as a silent
partner in shown alongside the space and
guilt the Emperor's Imperial forces were
known as the Tsar Dakar the Tsar Dakar
were ruthless and they were believed to
be the greatest soldiers in the galaxy
the planet Arrakis also known as dune
was home to the most valued commodity in
the galaxy the spice melange which
extended life high-end awareness and was
key to space travel the structure of the
Empire is reformed several times
throughout the course of the doom series
at first resemble in medieval feudal
society and later a theocratic
dictatorship in dune Old Earth is
mentioned a few times but it is largely
forgotten only the most learned in the
dune universe such as the bene Jesuit
Reverend mother's remember old earth
both dune and the Foundation series deal
with predicting the future and using the
knowledge of what's to come to shape a
better path for Humanity in dune this is
done through press Ian's
brought on by a combination of special
genes and intake of the spice melange
and in foundation this is done through a
complex mathematical science called
cycle history as I mentioned before in
the Hyperion cantos by Dan Simmons only
176 of the 376 worlds within the
hegemony of man are parts of the world
web the world web is a system of unified
worlds connected by flat line and far
caster far caster technology allowed
instant travel between worlds and flat
line provides communication
the worlds within the web were
interdependent the rest of the worlds
are Outback planets which are considered
Protectorate of the hegemony force is
the name for the hegemony collected
armed forces there were four branches of
force force ground Force Marine Force
Navy and force space like both
foundation and dune the Hyperion series
involves the fall and rise of galactic
society when the hegemony of man
eventually fell the packs became the
primary governing body an organization
which rose to power due to the rise of
the Catholic Church which found a way to
offer immortality through the use of a
parasite known as the cruciform unlike
in the doom series and the foundation
series the origin of the planet Earth is
not lost in the midst of time as Old
Earth died the far casters and flat
lines were provided by the techno core
which evolved from AI software initially
created by humans and developed into an
independent society separate from
humanity the goals and motivations of
the Technic or are somewhat ambiguous at
the start of the series but much is
revealed as the series continues it is
curious that while at the start of this
series it seems that the people of the
Hyperion universe choose to work with
their AI counterparts by the start of
the doom series all Thinking Machines
have been destroyed and prohibited under
penalty of death the people of the doom
universe had seen the dangers of AI long
ago and believed that the potential cost
outweighed the benefits the foundation
series has a less pessimistic view of
artificial intelligence than both the
Dune series and Hyperion as maz robot
series deals with the moral implications
of AI technology and its interaction
with humankind as mob depicts AI as
almost human he seems to argue that
robots are every bit as alive as men
Hyperion is the only series out of the
three that involves some kind of time
travel in the Hyperion series it is not
only possible for the past to affect the
future but for the future to affect the
past as well in dune the future is
constantly shifting as different paths
are taken it is the quiz that's had Iraq
who can see the pattern who shapes
destiny through his choices the
foundation series seems to rely somewhat
on the assumption of determinism which
is the belief in philosophy that all
events are determined by previously
existing causes therefore even
far-reaching future outcomes can be
predicted through calculation these
three series are some of my favorite
examples of galactic empires but of
course there are many others throughout
science fiction George Lucas's Star Wars
Jerry Pournelle is code dominium series
even games like Warhammer 40,000 which
is set within the Imperium of man they
all share similar characteristics they
usually depend on some form of FTL
travel in order to maintain connectivity
between worlds whether it is achieved
through far casting or hyperspace due to
the size of such civilizations there's
almost always some unrest and resistance
against the authority of the Empire the
foundation series and the doom series
are classics the Hyperion cantos is one
of the best science fiction series
involving a Galactic Empire to come out
of the modern era
doom built on the work that Asimov did
in his foundation series and Dan Simmons
brought even more new ideas to the
concept through the work of these
talented writers we can glimpse the
potential futures of mankind beyond the
planet earth the possibilities are as
endless as a universe itself thank you
guys so much for watching if you liked
the video make sure you like and
subscribe for more content and also
consider supporting this channel on
patreon if you really enjoy the content
I'm hoping to continue to dive deeper
into both the foundation series and
Hyperion alongside dune and A Song of
Ice and Fire on this channel so be on
the lookout for that and if you're
interested in voting on video topics
also click the patreon link in the
description